i want to congratulate malta being malta
in jurassic world dominion i love the
stuff that takes place in your city uh
so one of the things that i'm so curious
about is that the world is competing
more and more for revenue from film and
television and i'm just curious as the
commissioner what are you doing in malta
to sort of
uh you know help bring in uh that kind
of revenue in 2019 we launched our new
cashier bait program
which we increased the cash rebate from
25 27 to 40 percent and we kept they
were talking about us today our cash
ebay program is still top
within europe
we um we have a very solid program
reputable
we never defaulted our program has been
in operation since 2005.
and we strengthened our cash rebate
program even recently
by um by changing our atl so
we are attracting more business
more more filmmakers towards more so we
have a very strong reputable program for
the cashier bait we are known for the
locations versus our locations that we
can develop from southern france to the
middle east we have excellent crew and
our crew base is being strengthened and
increased every day we are creating more
opportunities every day
and then we are also known for the water
tanks
which were known globally built 1964 and
1979 respectively
we are investing heavily
in film infrastructure why government is
investing heavily in film infrastructure
35 million euro project master plan of
the motto film studios where we'll be
building world class sound stages our
vision is very clear we want to create
a a world-class film industry immortal
based on a sustainable industry based on
careers and i believe that we are on the
march to achieve that vision talk a
little bit about what it meant to you
uh personally and for the country to
have actually malta be malta in jurassic
world and not malta substituting for
some other city we are so proud we are
so proud and
this is not just about creating jobs and
you know the ripple effects of the film
industry on our economy but it's also
the impact on the brand image of malta
so the film industry is making its
impact there too
and uh we are also doing our shirt to
to get more tourists this time
interested in film business in film
locations to come to muda and um and and
and and visit the locations and learn
uh about uh our film track record
as i said yesterday in my speech
we are
very proud of our track record in
filmmaking
but we are not chained to that history
we want to make the next 100 years
better than the first 100 years and we
have the ambition multang is a small
country but a great nation with a big
ambition we never surrendered to
challenges and
and look it's in our culture it's in us
it's in our character it's in our
culture it's in our history that
we love winning and when we work to work
together we win i'm incredibly excited
for ridley scott's napoleon which uh he
recently shot here uh what was it like
having such you know joaquin phoenix
here and uh ridley coming back to your
country yeah um
for watching it was the second time for
ridley was the third time
and
the first uh movie that really shot here
was white squall
at the film studios at our water tanks
this was in 1996 then he came back for
gladiator he positioned positioned us on
the global map shot in 1999 at forza
crossley and bergo we built big sets we
built the coliseum for gladiator and and
again he came for napoleon where would i
build up for france
a few months ago we doubled up for the
battle of leon
and
we saw phoenix coming back
we we are
so
so positive
of getting business back
of building up relationships with
directors and producers and studios well
recently we had russell crowe with his
film prize fighter a a british fan and
we are building up a relationship with
with directors like ridley like russell
like colin to ensure that motor remains
on the map and delivering our promise to
create a world-class film industry in
malta one of the things that i i enjoyed
was seeing the dinosaurs around the city
where you you have blue um and i forget
the name of the square we have blue and
beta blue at st george square uh blue is
it's cool uh but that's part of a huge
sequence that has the massive dinosaurs
have you guys thought about doing
anything with massive dinosaurs on
display our idea is that and we will be
discussing
this with university pictures to ensure
that we keep strengthening our screen
tourism in water on that note uh
congratulations for everything and um i
hope that a lot more things are filming
here thank you so much